I want to know I wanted him to talk
about emptying the tank like there guys
that empty the tank few people know like
women who have kids understand what it
is to like use every single ounce of
your being to like go through pregnancy
and like push out a child right yeah
they understand what it is to empty the
tank and you get a [ __ ] human being
and I think certain athletes can empty
the tank Kobe could empty the [ __ ]
tank Jordan I think was the epitome of
empty alley empty the tank right LeBron
can do it no I think he can I think
Game seven against the Celtics or he
played all forty eight he can do it on
occasion I think Game seven oh yeah yeah
yeah it can happen it's not a whenever I
want to
yeah into it wants to yeah I think yeah
or he might be afraid to like the cab
season when like his mom was getting
stroked out by Delonte West like he
couldn't empty the tank right delante
empty hey sure right well Jordan was
struggling right now Jordan but LeBron
was struggling right I wonder I want to
know the cost of empty in the tank like
I want to hear Jordan go like every time
you empty the tank you lose a little bit
of that tank for good like every time
you go down 2-0 on the power bar the
power bar shrinks a little as well like
I want it like how many Tour de France's
can you [ __ ] do you know you hear
like people go every Tour de France you
do takes a little away from your life I
haven't heard that yeah they said like
you lose years of your life doing a Tour
de France right now who the [ __ ] knows
like you also gain years of your life
because you're in such great shape that
you're gonna be able to deal with these
things doesn't matter but I'm curious
like what does it feel like to
completely empty the tank and like what
is the cost of that long-term I think
we're seeing the cost I mean he looks
terrible he [ __ ] looks [ __ ] like his
eyes look horrible always looked like
jaundiced like yellow why are yellow
yeah I don't know I can't explain that I
don't know what the [ __ ] that is because
I thought it was jaundice but it's like
nah he's still alive his liver is he
talks like he's fine he see
like he's fine but there's something
going on yeah and he's taking care of
that drink that drink is tall and it is
brown liquor and throughout the
interview nose down yeah okay I was like
looking it up I thought it was just
always full low as [ __ ] yeah I was at
that [ __ ] but I'm just curious about
that like guys really can [ __ ] empty
the tank cuz I remember even like
playing ball growing up like I always
felt like I could give more than you you
know what I mean like I was just willing
to just give more I'll sacrifice more
I'll be more exhausted I'll do whatever
it takes until like to quit like I
thought I could that's something I could
control right and I want to know the
extreme that yeah like what is it like
when you have nothing yeah like when
people run marathons and [ __ ] to me it
was never impressive right cuz I was
like uh it hurts I did you so it just
hurts and then and you know my girl runs
in my damn room but like I'm like all
right so you're in pain like you deal
with that it's not that impressive so
it's not like you just deal with it like
the only ones I'm impressed by are the
ones who like make good time running a
marathon I'm gonna leave impressed by
the swimming one oh they'll try that
[ __ ] the Ironman where you do all three
yeah I shoulda spiking stupid you get to
sit swimming is the one that impresses
me because if you stop you die okay you
could drown like when you stop running
now you're standing right like the
second you stop running your foot you're
chilling yeah but swimming you could die
so that was always super impressive
especially when they're open ocean that
one I'm like oh boy you you can't empty
the tanks women you cannot do it the
cost of emptying the tank swimming is
death
[Applause]